[Music]
foreign
just a final question here is there any
sort of work being done to you with the
airlines
in order to get flights actually on time
or not delayed as much just curious if
there's any work happening there yes so
we've seen a almost a doubling in terms
of improvement on on-time performance
since last year that is a reflection of
all the work that we've done across the
ecosystem together with our partner
Airlines with agencies reducing
processing time reducing wait times and
fine-tuning operations with our air
carrier partners and we see the great
results that have come from that
foreign
man who deserves an award I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's July 25th
2023 we're live streaming on the rumble
the locals and the YouTube subscribe if
you have not post game show as always
reubenreport.locals.com and we are just
a couple days away from me going off the
grid dipping out no phone no TV no
newspapers no communication with the
outside world just sitting in a cold
dark room waiting to return and uh
looking forward to that Thursday will be
my last day on the grid we're doing a
live meet up Thursday night for our
locals Community if you want to join us
reubenupport.locals.com it's the pin
post for subscribers only and I'm being
told on the Fly that we have a Tuesday
test for me I did not know about this I
guess Tuesday is going to be our test
day all right so you've got some sort of
question for me is that what's going on
here you have three questions for me
okay today's Tuesday test I'm getting
this on the Fly what is older here
oh this is good what is older Nancy
Pelosi or the microwave oven
wow that is good that is good so Nancy
Pelosi's got to be what she's got to be
early 80s 82 something like that right
and then the microwave oven
I'm guessing came out in the 50s so it's
close it's definitely close
um
I'm commercially though probably not
till a bit later than that I'm gonna say
Nancy Pelosi is older than the microwave
oven
yeah I got it wow Nancy Pelosi uh born
in
1945 oh no the oven wait what am I being
told here
the oven came out in 1945 Nancy Pelosi
came out in 1940. okay that's good one
for one pretty good what is older Joe
Biden or Tupperware there's definitely a
theme today Joe Biden or Tupperware
Tupperware seems kind of new to me that
Tupperware seems like an like a 70s or
80s a bunch of women would get together
and and you know share Tupperware with
each other so I'm going to say Joe Biden
is older than Tupperware
wow two for two uh Tupperware uh came
out in 1946 so I was a bit off on that
one Joe Biden came out in 1942. we are
educating the people today
finally what is older Donald Trump or
paper straws
Donald Trump or paper stores well Donald
Trump is what he just turned 79
something like that
the paper straw
I feel like the paper straw has been
around for a while you know what I mean
people enjoy the straw people were
drinking lemonade back in the day on The
Veranda with a nice paper straw I'm
going to say paper straws are older than
Donald Trump paper straws came out in
1888.
thank you ladies and gentlemen uh not
bad we did not rehearse any of that I
did not even know what was happening
there you go the theme for today's
program which I did know about uh is a
bit about this Barbie divide happening
in the country but fear not I'm not
going to belabor you with everything
going on with Barbie and focus on Barbie
and all that we do a little barbieness
but I think Barbie and the culture wars
and the woke versus the same people and
the destruction of old stories like I
talked about yesterday Snow White if you
don't like the story of the guy kissing
the princess and living happily ever
after instead of destroying that story
how about you create a new story if you
don't like whatever it is Barbie was all
about big boobs and a genderless dude or
whatever Barbie with her car then create
a new story but they like to burn down
everything and that's what the machine
is good at destroying anything that
Americans can broadly agree on and then
giving us remakes that just make us hate
each other and then we're going to
connect that to a whole bunch of
politics including the big thing going
on here in Florida because today is a
day that ends in the letter Y which
means the entire machine is going after
Florida going after DeSantis claiming
that we are not teaching uh slavery
correctly in our schools and a whole
bunch more and of course when I saw the
headline on this a few days ago without
even having to read the articles I knew
it was complete nonsense but that didn't
stop Kamala Harris from getting on a
plane and flying to Florida and telling
everyone how race it is racist this
place is and all of the mainstream media
and all that and then we'll do a bit on
Trump and DeSantis because some of you
saw this I'm sure but I went on Charlie
Kirk's show yesterday Charlie Kirk of
course from turning point USA Charlie's
a friend of mine we've done dozens and
dozens of public events over the years
we're in different spots when it comes
to Trump and it's not this but we got
into it in an interesting
I would say in an interesting and
respectful way with completely different
perspectives and we don't see too much
of that these days do we whether it's a
Democrat versus a republican in a
respectable manner or even let's say two
people that are going to vote Republican
me and Charlie having an honest
discussion about why we're supporting
one candidate or the other so we're
going to do all of that but before we do
let's talk about my Link Box you guys
know that 60 of U.S pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day well guys there is a better
way I want to tell you about Mike you
know Mike that's mood plus oink moink
delivers grass-fed and grass-finish beef
and lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door you choose the
meat delivered in every box like rib
eyes to chicken breasts to pork chops to
salmon fillets and much more plus you
can cancel anytime and you guys know I
love taking a little filet mignon out on
my big green egg on a Friday night Shark
Tank host Kevin O'Leary called moink's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and they guarantee you will say oink
oink I'm just so happy and I got moist
keep American farming going by signing
up at boinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time and now back to me okay so
when we were setting up the show this
morning and Phoenix said to me Dave
let's cover a little bit of what's going
on with this Barbie situation and
everyone's freaking out about Barbie we
had a little back and forth because I
was saying I don't want to always just
because something happens culturally and
everyone's freaking out I don't want to
always add into the freak out right I'm
trying to give you guys Solutions on
this show but sometimes things happen
that I would say are so culturally
uh impactful whether we like it or not
that we have to address it so I am going
to talk about Barbie for a moment we're
going to show you a clip of the movie I
did not see the movie as I said
yesterday I am an adult I did not see
Barbie over the weekend I did watch uh
Flash Gordon but you know that's a
little bit different obviously
um
but I'm going to show you a clip but I'm
not telling you all of this to outrage
you I just want to show you how a
certain set of people are trying to push
a certain set of ideas and then really
on the other side of that how we can
fight back in a better more functional
way so here is Ken you know who's the
actor on this one that's uh Ryan Gosling
if I'm not mistaken Ryan Gosling as Ken
singing about blonde fragility in the
new Barbie movie
like
I just don't know who I am without you
you're 10 but it's Barbie and Ken
there is no just Ken
doesn't seem to matter what
I'm always number two
no one knows how hard I tried
I have feelings that I can't explain
driving me insane
all my life been so polite cause I'm
just kidding anywhere else
is it my destiny
[Music]
all right so first off I want to just
reiterate I am not here to make you
outraged by that I don't think you
should have been outraged by that I
think there's obviously and we just all
agreed on it in this room and I think
I'm sitting here with three
heterosexuals as far as I know there was
something visually interesting about
that is there anything you guys want to
tell me about your sexuality real quick
anyone we're good we're good
Phoenix is I'm a canonical asexual
that's a reference from last week if
you're paying attention
um anyway there's something visually
interesting about that but the point I'm
showing you on this and then we'll get
to sort of the outrage machine around it
is that here you have what they've done
is they've flipped which is just fine
they flipped what the traditional thing
is right here is the guy now saying I'm
not complete without the girl that's
okay they're flipping the script on that
and again there's something visually
interesting the song wasn't terrible uh
but now there's this giant culture War
raging around this is the destruction of
men and men now need women and the other
sides trying to take out the people
saying that and all that I thought the
daily wire had a nice piece that could
that sum this up quite well uh early
reviewers praise the film as being
pro-feminist and anti-patriarchy Gerwig
that's the director has crafted a fierce
funny and deeply feminist Adventure that
dares you to laugh and cry even if
you're made of plastic Entertainment
Weekly reporter Devin kogan wrote the
writer goes on to describe how in Barbie
land the women run the show while the
Ken dolls always play a supporting role
but then stereotypical Barbie played by
Margot Robbie starts to unravel mentally
when she starts thinking about deeper
issues such as death and realizes her
arched feet have gone flat she Ventures
into the real world to figure out what's
going on once Barbie and Ken Ryan
Gosling begin rollerblading around La
however they both realize that they've
essentially entered a mirror Dimension
where are the female presidents the CEOs
the astronauts Gerwig tackles the doll's
complicated Legacy head-on exploring how
Barbie's reputation here isn't one of
leadership or creativity but of
corporatized objectification Barbie
herself is horrified facing crude
comments and misogyny for the first time
in her plastic life the ew review also
notes that Gosling as Ken becomes
enamored with the idea of being the boss
and tries to bring that power structure
back to Barbie land to can this newfound
idea of patriarchy is intoxicating any
quick enters a spiral of masculinity
luxurating in trucks Cowboys hats and
The Addictive thrill of power the
reviewer writes he says of the film
Greta Gerwig loads plenty of food for
thought in a hot pink pop Fantasia
poking fun at patriarchy and corporate
parent Mattel in her treatment of the
iconic girls can do anything dull in
Barbie land Ken's job is a deliberately
ill-defined afterthought basically just
Beach whereas in the real world dude's
rule an idea he takes back to Barbie
land with pointedly absurd results
brainwashing all the women into behaving
like obedient Housewives he shares later
in the review so this is connected to
what I talked about yesterday that
instead of creating new characters to do
all of these new things whether it's
snow white whether it's Star Wars
whether it's Barbie whether it's Marvel
if you want to change all of these new
things if you want to change the history
the lore of these characters if you want
to change their sexuality their gender
their skin color Little Mermaid all of
these things if you want to do all that
that is just fine that is what dreamers
dream of right writing new stories
creating new characters new tensions new
worlds new ideas that's once what the
great legendary writers did when they
created say Star Wars or they created
Lord of the Rings or they created
anything that you watch that is a
fictitious something a love story or
whatever else but instead what we do
right now is the corporate world takes
old properties that were just fine in
and of themself they really were and
then tries to put this modern spin on
them to show us how evil the patriarchy
is and all of the usual stuff we wanted
to show you one little clip we saw this
going around this is interesting this is
from the Barbie Premiere in Spain look
what's oh God yes Queen oh my God yes ow
wow merge man lady and oh my God guys
what's that about yours isn't that more
of Willy Wonka thing and now look at
that
so how are we connecting this to other
things well the point is guys that the
the woke thing like you could see again
I'm not enraged by this if you want to
see Barbie go see Barbie okay fine yada
yada yada but the woke thing that that
destructive Force has permeated
throughout Society everywhere so now I
want to connect it to something
politically that's happening of course
right here in the Free State of Florida
because the Flames of the woke they end
up burning everything down one of the
things that's happening right now is
Florida is being attacked well the
Department of Education in Florida
specifically and of course that means
around descendants are being attacked
because they are claiming that somehow
we are not teaching black history
correctly that we are not teaching about
slavery correctly and much more again I
want to reiterate that when I saw this
story just a headline a couple days ago
I knew we'd cover it on the show in the
next couple days but I didn't even
bother clicking because I was like it's
so obviously nonsensical that there's no
point addressing it so my Hope was it
was going to just go away of course it
did not here is CBS News they're a very
serious corporate press organization
covering this very serious and real
story
controversy over Florida's new education
standards after Governor Ron DeSantis
signed a bill called the stop woke act
last year the changes include teaching
middle schoolers that some enslaved
people actually benefited from slavery
because it taught them skills Nancy
Cordis is following all of this at the
White House good morning Nancy
good morning John yes this debate may
have started in Florida but it has now
landed squarely in the middle of the
presidential race
I didn't do it and I wasn't involved in
it Florida's Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis tried to distance himself from
the curriculum controversy but it didn't
work I didn't do it and I'm not involved
in it are not the words of leadership
Florida's new history teaching
guidelines approved last week stemmed
from a 2022 law Governor DeSantis called
the stop woke act Governor DeSantis
started this fire with the bill that he
signed the new standards say Florida
students should be taught about the
harsh conditions slaves endured but also
about how slaves developed skills which
in some instances could be applied for
their personal benefit they're probably
going to show some of the folks that
eventually parlayed uh you know being a
blacksmith into into doing things later
later in life that comment drew a swift
rebuke from fellow Republican
presidential candidate will Hurd okay
now that sounds very very scary now
first off I just want to address one
thing about the skills issue because
that's what seems to be everyone seems
to be hung up on this skills thing you
know there is a uncomfortable truth
related to this no one is defending the
hard absolute horrors of slavery a human
being has no right to own another human
being and in the United States of
America we fought a civil war very close
to our Inception to eliminate slavery
slavery existed long before the United
States slavery was not one of the
founding principles of the United States
all of those things the the simple truth
and we'll get to the way they're
exaggerating all of this nonsense is
that if you attain some skill however
you attained it uh it's still a skill so
if you were a blacksmith on the
plantation you were able to take that
skill out you didn't immediately become
an accountant the day slavery was over
that is no defense of slavery whatsoever
and I have no doubt the media matter
losers are watching this right now
waiting for me to say it in some way
that they can selectively edit um but
there is a truth to that you could make
the same argument and here we go I mean
I know what's going to happen already
but in the work camps right in World War
II Nazi war camps they used they took
people that had certain skills to do
certain things to build buildings and do
an engineering horrible things you might
have learned some skills there it
doesn't mean any of it's good none of
it's good none of it's none of it's just
but it doesn't change a certain degree
of reality but of course I'm going to
unpack why this is all nonsense but
let's just do one more thing this is a
political a political reporter uh Eugene
Daniels uh really explaining again this
is sort of the hysteria around this this
is mostly because white kids feel about
uncomfortable about reality
this teaching is uh from the Florida new
curriculum there but also how Governor
DeSantis and his anti-world policies
have put him in a box with the speaking
to a seemingly smaller and smaller
portion of the electorate this is what
happens when you base your entire kind
of political
um career on this when you say that um
everybody needs to be anti-wolf that's
where this is where you end up and when
you talk to folks in Florida
um the whole point of the bill that came
through this is in reaction to a bill
that he wanted it was making clear what
he wanted to folks
um and it's because he felt a lot of
people around this country are starting
to feel that we can't teach the correct
history of this country because it makes
white kids uncomfortable that is at the
base of this right that it is
uncomfortable to hear that people that
look like you put people that look like
me in Chains and made them do things and
beat them and rape them that is
uncomfortable for kids to hear that is
what folks that is what these folks are
saying but then when you use that as a
political control you have to own it
right at this point this is all Juan Ron
DeSantis it is he may not have created
these policies um or um with the school
board but at the end of the day he made
it very clear to what he wanted to the
folks in this okay everything he said
there is complete nonsense and if he
wants to teach oh
kid fourth grader fifth grader sixth
grader whatever it might be
people who look like you did this to
people who look like me thus we must
have Equity right thus I must get a job
instead of you thus I must get into the
college instead of you that's the world
that that guy wants to live in right
that's the world that the Supreme Court
just struck down uh the the decision to
allow affirmative action as it relates
to getting into colleges thankfully the
Supreme Court did the right thing
because we don't want systemic racism
the idea that DeSantis is doing
something because white kids are nervous
about hearing reality no it's not true
but before I get to any of that I'm just
going to lay out more of the way the
media are treating this versus reality
we'll get to reality I promise you uh
here's Whoopi Goldberg completely lying
about the thing
trying to get through everything that's
happened over the weekend and what's all
the insanity going on in the world like
Wednesday uh Florida's Board of
Education approved
what they're calling standards for uh
African-American history I feel like
they didn't talk to any
African-Americans because we could have
told them about the history and nor have
any anyone seemingly gone to the
Smithsonian we're telling you this
history it's our American history
because you need to know so we don't
repeat it and here you come to Santa's
trying to repeat away you know what as
long as the Smithsonian is standing as
long as there are books as long as there
are families because remember we didn't
have books all these stories come to us
from our families you don't call our
families Liars they know what happened
because their Grandma's Grandma's
Grandma's Grandma told them you sir are
you are I can't I can't even say the
word you're a disgrace we'll be right
back all right first off Whoopi you
gotta lay off the pipe I've heard from
multiple sources you show up to that to
show stoned every day um I don't know
what the high hell you're talking about
DeSantis is not trying to reinstate
Institute slavery or teach anyone that
slavery didn't exist or anything like
that but you flat out lied when she said
that they should have talked to some
black Scholars about this uh because two
of the scholars that were on the board
who put this whole curriculum together
and by the way we're going to read you
some of the curriculum and link to it
down below uh you will find it is it in
the description already yeah it's in the
description already if you're watching
this video right now we've already
linked to it don't watch don't read it
while I'm telling you about it but yes
there are two Scholars who are black
they are African-American Dr William B
Allen and Dr Francis Presley rice so
everything you just said there was
complete nonsense and speaking of
complete nonsense The View actually had
to cut a portion of Anna Navarro's
insane diatribe we're about to show you
because because she was using some foul
language
I'm you know I live in Florida I have
I have bad uh about the cultural Wars
that Rhonda Santos has been creating so
when he says that he has nothing to do
with it
a bunch of blackies and minions to put
that legislation into effect he has
created the environment that has led to
this how dare you shame on you people in
Florida how dare you try to whitewash
slavery and to the commissioner of
Education in Florida many Diaz a
cuban-american that is like saying that
there's a redeeming quality to Cuban
political prisoners under Castro when
you don't have freedom you don't have
anything and for this man Rhonda Sanders
was apparently his only skill that he
has acquired is lying and creating
culture wars that he thinks are going to
make him president they're not buddy
that's why you're 30 points down Anna I
beg you to leave this horrific racist
hellhole known as Florida please leave
don't put yourself through this it's
making you very very angry again guys
we're going to get to the facts in just
a moment but one more from The View
because after Whoopi lied about there
being no black scholar is on the thing
Alyssa Farah she's the pet Republican
they pay her about a million bucks a
year to Pat her on the head and pretend
she's a republican so she can always go
after Republicans she actually
acknowledged that yeah well there were
some black Scholars who wrote the
curriculum
I reached out to the Santa says I
reached out to the Santos team this
weekend honestly in hopes that there was
some decent explanation here and
basically what I got from them was well
there were some black Educators and
Scholars who contributed to this and
it's been on the books for over a decade
a lot of things have been on the books
for over a decade that shouldn't be and
they're bad and they're terrible my
friend will Hurd I think said it better
than I could have which was it was
literally the most dehumanizing
institution subjugated people as
property because they lacked any basic
rights and freedoms this is Ron DeSantis
doing what I wanted to think there was
better to him but I wonder I'm realizing
there's not
okay so there she is she's not doing it
to debunk whoopee but she's going on
their train their train of lives let's
continue with the train of lies because
the thing that really lit this on fire
was that vice president Kamala Harris
the queen of Venn diagrams uh she was
very upset about this and then she
appeared in Florida here's a little
video of her freaking out about this
thing that's not real a thing we'll get
to that
and while they while they exist check it
out
visionist history
just yesterday in the State of Florida
they decided middle school students will
be taught that enslaved people benefited
from slavery
they insult Us in an attempt to Gaslight
us and we will not stand for it
okay she's very outraged about what's
going on here so
um
so look at this I have a piece of paper
in front of me and you're not going to
believe this we've got the actual
information about what's going on here
uh this is from the National Review I'll
read it to you carefully and you'll get
all of it I have been trying to work out
how to best illustrate the sheer scale
of Harris's falsehood and I've come to
the conclusion that the only way to
achieve it is to list in one place all
of the relevant parts of the courts
about which she is complaining So Below
I have copied and pasted every single
reference to Slaves the slavery slaves
abolitionism civil rights and African
Americans that is in the document for
those interested the full in the full
curriculum including curriculum for
teaching of the Holocaust is here by the
way as I just said we've linked to it in
our video that you're watching right now
so you can read the entire thing for
yourself there is simply no way of
pursuing of perusing this course and
concluding that it gaslights people or
whitewashes slavery among many many
other things it includes sections on the
conditions for Africans during their
passage to America the living conditions
of slaves in British North American
colonies the Caribbean Central America
and South America including infant
mortality rates the harsh conditions and
their consequences on British American
plantations for example under
nourishment climate conditions infant
and child mortality rates of the
enslaved versus the free the harsh
conditions in the Caribbean plantations
poor nutrition rigorous labor disease
how the South tried to prevent slaves
from escaping in their efforts to end
the Underground Railroad the
overwhelming death rates caused by the
practice the many ways in which Africans
resisted slavery the ramifications of
prejudice racism and stereotyping on
individual freedoms and the struggles
faced by African-American women in the
19th century as it relates to issues of
suffrage business and access to
education many of these modules apply to
Florida specifically so yes Florida is
going all in on teaching reality there
is nothing being whitewashed or anything
else but you guys get it you guys get it
if you do anything
anything that is remotely against the
woke they will come and try to destroy
you and lie about you and it will be all
the way up from the vice president often
it's the president himself but from the
VP to the harpies at the view to CBS to
the activists online the whole freaking
thing believe it or not I am still
shocked about this I am I am so shocked
I may fall out of my chair as we play
you this video on CNN of all places they
had this guy by the name of Scott
Jennings and he actually told the truth
what's amazing to me that how little
Kamala Harris apparently has to do this
she can read something on Twitter one
day and be on an airplane the next to
make something literally out of nothing
this is a completely made up deal
I looked at the standards I even looked
at an analysis of the standards and
every instance where the word slavery or
slave was used I even read the statement
of the African-American Scholars that
wrote the standards not Rhonda santis
but the scholars everybody involved in
this says this is completely a
fabricated issue and yet look how
quickly Kamala Harris jumped on it so
the fact that this is her best moment a
fabricated matter is pretty ridiculous
in my opinion okay so what I would like
you to do if you care about this issue
at all is actually after the show just
read what's in it we gave you a nice
summary from the National Review right
there but you know this is what I'm
trying to show you is the Playbook that
these people use if you do anything
right DeSantis was coming for the Gaze
and then he was coming for a trans and
now he's coming for black people and you
know these things are all lies right
this is the freest most flourishing
state in the Union and I want to talk a
little bit more about that right now uh
because Prager you and you guys know
I've had many connections with prageru
over the years Dennis has become I would
say a mentor and a bonus Uncle to me
I've done I think four of their
five-minute videos I've done a series of
other things with them but prageru has
become an incredible idea Powerhouse of
Sanity taking people all over the
political Spectrum who are fighting
radicalism giving them a platform often
people who don't agree with a lot of
things that say a traditional
conservative might agree with such as me
such as Tim Poole such as Jordan
Peterson and many others and allowing
them to spread their ideas because there
are good time-tested ideas that should
flourish in a place that's set up for
many people of different walks of life
and different views well Florida now is
once again going on offense so it's
going to be lied about on this front
Florida will be incorporating some
prageru materials in the education
system this is absolutely wonderful I
want to read a quote about it from the
Miami new time so this is out this is a
leftist drag here's how they're framing
it which is consistent with everything
else that we just showed you prageru a
conservative non-profit often criticized
for downplaying systemic racism and
promoting anti-immigrant theories
announced today that Florida is the
first state to officially approve
prageru as an educational vendor a press
release from the group States this fall
in schools Across America students will
be watching prageru videos in their
classrooms as States officially make
prageru an approved educational resource
the group claims it is partnering with
as many states as possible to provide a
conservative lesson plans touted as
prageru kids in response to requests
from teachers who are sick and tired of
curriculum laced with radical political
agendas according to the press release
in the past teachers have been
disciplined even fired for showing
prageru videos in their classroom Now
prageru videos are not only being
allowed in classrooms but
superintendents and education
Commissioners are actively encouraging
teachers to use use Prague or use
content to educate their students
prageru's supplemental curriculum offers
an easy cutting-edge weight Cutting Edge
way to teach core knowledge in subjects
ranging from Civics and history to
entrepreneurship and financial literacy
Governor Ron DeSantis office didn't
immediately respond to a request for
comment via email prageru's announcement
comes as Florida adopts new academic
standards for black history classes in
public schools with accordance with the
state's controversial stop woke act
signed into law by DeSantis in 2022 the
legislation restricts instruction
regarding systemic racism and bars
Educators from teaching that people are
privileged or oppressed solely because
of their race national origin or sex
introduced in the fifth grade the very
section on slavery in Florida's black
history curriculum closely mirrors a
Prager use segment in which conservative
pundit Candace Owens who is Black
reminds viewers that slavery was not
invented by white people in response to
a request for comment the Florida
Department of Education says that it
reviewed prageru kids and determined the
material aligns to Florida's revised
Civics and government standards
whew that was a lot of reading couple
things I'd like to address there first
off Candace was right slavery was not
invented by white people and even if it
was it wouldn't make all white people
bad and all black people good just
inherently based on that fact uh the
opening paragraph on that Phoenix can
you give me the line on the opening
paragraph on that again because it's
really just great the way they frame
everything look at this a conservative
nonprofit often criticized for
downplaying systemic racism the way
they're framing it is that systemic
racism exists except it doesn't and they
do videos debunking it and actually the
Supreme Court by eliminating affirmative
action has just kneecapped systemic
racism and also the next one and
promoting anti-immigrant theories they
don't promote anti-immigrant theories
they promote that we should have a
border that the nation-state is actually
important that some people are legal
members of a society and some people are
not so it is absolutely wonderful that
prageru will be part whatever it is part
of the milieu of the Florida education
system and the media will go nuts and
they will lie about all of it just like
they're lying about what's happening in
Florida right now and you will see it
relentlessly and the whole purpose of
today's show was whether they're showing
you uh uh the entertainment style Barbie
things where they're destroying old
things or where they're whether they're
lying to you about what's in your
child's curriculum you got to figure out
better ways out of this so that gets me
to the to the last segment today because
I was on Charlie Kirk's radio show
yesterday they it's video and radio it's
mostly a radio show but they simulcast
the video uh and we got into the
DeSantis uh Trump situation I just want
to say as I said up top Charlie and I
have been friends for years we've done
dozens and dozens of events together
usually with Turning Point USA uh
Charlie is firmly in the Trump Camp
Turning Point from my humble opinion is
basically a trump uh campaign arm right
like that that they that's what they of
in effect are but Charlie was gracious
enough to have me on his show to say
what I think about DeSantis uh so he
asked me to make the case for governor
DeSantis here you go kind of make the
case especially to our conservative
audience and then secondly how do you
think his campaign is currently going
you
Essence should be loving every single
thing that Ron DeSantis has done I don't
know one thing that Ron DeSantis uh has
not done that we would have wanted him
to do Florida is safe its economy is
absolutely booming we fund the police
here we're getting ESG out of our
institutions we've done that which
that's actually perhaps the biggest
issue that people don't talk about that
often because it's kind of In The Weeds
on how corporations are putting wokeness
on all of us I know you talk about it
but the average person doesn't and they
certainly don't incorporate America uh
he has fought Disney he has fought the
endless racialization of our children by
getting rid of this AP African-American
studies course that was in essence going
to teach gender Theory we've gotten some
of these books that are sexualizing our
children out of schools he has done
literally everything that anyone
right-leaning could believe in or or
could possibly want to happen I would
say he's done one or two things that are
a little bit more right-leaning than I
would want oh they're perfect for me
Dave I gotta say I love that stuff no
no absolutely but I would ask you what
is there anything that Ron DeSantis
you're you're at least a partner no he
he's he's America's greatest Governor
I've said that and I and by the way I've
said that repeatedly okay so it was good
to hear first off I want to credit
Charlie Charlie brought me on his show
to let me say what I believed in as
obviously I went ahead and did it
Charlie said right there that uh
DeSantis has been America's greatest
Governor he later went on to say that I
think his exact quote was 100 when I
asked him if DeSantis was the best
Governor when it came to covid uh and
then we got into a little bit of my
criticisms around Trump I thought you
might find this one interesting
but here's what I would like to see out
of DeSantis we could talk after the
break Dave you know when we go to a
college campus you say hey if you
disagree go to the front of the line I
want to say I want to see somebody get
in the arena and say hey
I I'm willing to throw out the script
I'm willing to just take any question
I'm willing to kind of just fight it's
more kind of total and attitudinal
um Dave your reaction 20 seconds will
pick it up after the break
sure so look if in essence and we'll
pick it up after the break if in essence
your your point is oh I agree with
virtually all of the policies and nobody
has accomplished more than this guy and
done everything I want to do but but
there's a little bit of a marketing
issue here all right I'll go with you on
that and I think that can be dealt with
the base is very smart and they're
constantly looking in a way of who's
going to betray me next this is the
advice I gave to DeSantis privately and
publicly and right now the Rubicon has
been crossed where they think the Santa
is going to betray I'm not even saying
that's fair but I'm not saying it's
fairly I mean Trump trump has done far
more to betray the truth and and in a
certain way the the respect of the base
every time he lies about dissent right
so when he lies about covid and Florida
who was the best governor for Covenant
covet in the country DeSantis 100 but
who has more in who has done more work
and more praise for Paul Ryan is it
Rhonda santis or Donald Trump
for Paul Ryan I can't I can't speak
either way but at the same time we could
talk about going after the break either
way I mean I can show you plenty of
videos of trump talking about how much
you love it
okay now again credit to Charlie he
brought me on the show I I was clearly
ready to do it I later on read him the
direct quote where uh Governor DeSantis
says that he has spoke to Paul Ryan once
since being governor and I think not
once with Karl robe since he's been
Governor I might be getting that
backwards right now
um uh Charlie didn't have much on that
uh I wanted to show you one other clip
uh in terms of the what we were getting
to there about what there's a difference
between getting the ideas right having
the right set of policies and all that
and what you're doing in terms of
campaigning and making the argument
against the other guy
I will agree with you that in terms of
some of the strategy of the rollout they
probably should have been more
aggressive I do see that changing look
DeSantis just went on uh Russell Brand
last week uh he just went on CNN for the
first time last week I think he's doing
Megan Kelly this week if I'm not uh
mistaken and she's been very very
critical of him uh Russell's a lefty I
mean he certainly uh is you know no one
that you would call a traditional
conservative by any stretch I would love
to see him go on The View sit directly
with those women and call out their
Endless Lies about Florida you know Anna
Navarro who lives in Miami who rails
against Florida every day he should sit
right next to her and call her out
um so if you want if your question is
really do you want to take some of the
the anger that the base has because of
the way Trump being treated at he's
being treated horribly and I completely
agree with that righteous I agree I
agree there's probably some way to do
that but I would also say to some extent
if you just want to view this in the
political lens maybe this is why Trump
should stop lying about DeSantis every
which way and you know he is everything
he says about the scientist is a lie
everything he says I'll be honest it's
also a lie when DeSantis goes after
Trump and says he was pro-faouchy and
all that that's just not true but it is
without you in a word on the way out
we're out of time Dave Rubin thanks so
much more after the break
[Music]
can I Pat myself on my on my back on my
show is that a little too self-relating
or something
um he did give fauci an award on the way
out and he did praise fauci endlessly
and
it's just so annoying to have to do this
because I get what Charlie's point is no
matter what you say what in essence
Charlie was saying to me it's
attitudinal and you know uh something
like that what he's saying is no matter
what you say that is true about Trump
unless you bow to the base and I think
what he actually says Bassy means donors
the Trump donors I think is what he
means uh that that they will come to
destroy you but the simple truth is
Trump ran we showed you the video once
maybe you know we'll try to find it for
the post game show uh but Trump when he
was running reelection ran a video
praising fauci as part of his
re-election that's just reality that
that is just reality and you have to
make of it what you will anyway the
point of all of this is that there is as
I've been trying to lay out more and
more and more and I will continue to and
then when I go off the grid I'll get
some time to gestate with it and think
about it and chew it and masticate it
and come back masticate I said nothing
that we have to get demonetized over I
know it sounded a little different
um I will come back with fresh eyes on
all of this but I think there is a way
out of this nonsense but we have to stop
the lives we have to stop the pure
partisanship we have to call out the
nonsense we have to stop burning down
everything that was once good and a
series of other things and I think we
have to have been honest
an honest debate at least those of us
that are right leaning on what should
happen in terms of this Trump to say at
this thing and I want to throw back to
One Clip we've played this once or twice
before but I think he makes a great
point this is Jordan Peterson on Piers
Morgan talking about the Trump DeSantis
situation
would you like him to run again would it
be good for America do you think
no I I don't think it would be good for
America
would it be good for him to run that's a
diff that's a difficult question because
it might be that it would be good for
America to have whether or not Donald
Trump should be president sorted out in
the public sphere debated intensely and
subject to an election so it might be
very interesting to see him put himself
forward on the Republican ticket if I
had my druthers and I say this I hope
with due care I would rather see someone
like DeSantis step forward who shares
some of that forthright
strength let's say that characterizes
Trump at his best but seems to be a more
uh cautious administrator and a less
divisive figure I think that would be
better
okay so I love how Jordan laid that out
we probably have to have this fight
publicly we're having this fight
publicly and I think the challenge for
you the challenge for me the challenge
for everybody is find the honest
Arbiters within this not not just
succumb to the trolls or whatever it
might be not just denigrate everybody
there are gajillions
roughly I'd have to check the Abacus of
great Trump supporters right of course
and I went to Trump rallies and these
are great people and all of those things
but as I've often said Trump make the
case for yourself stop insulting their
intelligence like I don't like if you're
going to make everyone think that up is
down and left is right and somehow
DeSantis was bad on covet and Florida
was worse than New York and that he's
dishonest and and not loyal like all of
this nonsense all of this nonsense but
we as a country will have to decide do
we want to burn it down and burn down
all of our old things or do we want to
figure out a way that will be more
honest and real whether it's in our
children's curriculum whether it's in
our entertainment or our politics the
question is posed and I suppose the
American people will answer it we've got
a post game show coming up in just
moments at
reubenreport.locals.com can we find that
ad that Trump put up about you and we'll
put that up uh in the post game we're
gonna see if we can grab that one uh
we've got a Obama Bud Light cold clothes
for you in moments and and your
questions coming up on the other side
thanks for watching Everybody two more
days then I disappear ciao
all right everyone so it's Friday night
I'm getting ready to go ow this is the
look I'm feeling kind but before I go
out I've got a pregame and the only way
I pre-game is with
an ice cold Bud Light
uh
so good ah
[Music]
oh